hello, how are you, greets you, jaramillo comes out
with a brief briefing for today tuesday
april 20 the nevada national guard
together with the
cork county fire department and the fbi
will do emergency drills
starting today these agents and
firefighters will be near the
sangres boulevard shopping center and
children's hospital near maryland parkway
and darling these drills will
run through thursday
some realistic ones will be observed
please do not call 911
if you see activity like this in the
above mentioned area
today as well  clark county leaders
will vote to remove
coronavirus restrictions in the
state starting May 1
all counties in the state will take
control over
pandemic-related safety measures so
far only 50 percent allowed
capacity in restaurants, shops and
gyms but this could change
leaders announced the reopening to  l 100%
possible by June 1
Families will be able to start
enrolling their children as of today for the
next school year within the
Clark County School District all
grades will be in-person
full time when school begins
in the fall  Parents
will still have the option of choosing for their
children to study from home,
however, it is six days clear that there will be
occasions when they have to
attend the institution, the deadline is
May 21,
now we will move on with the weather forecast.
expect a sunny day with
temperatures in the high 80s
tonight stronger winds will return
expect temperatures near normal and
a small chance of rain on
Thursday have a good day I am salt and
jaramillo with your brief informative of the
day
[Music]